it's okay
I'm here
It's been a while since you've had nightmares.
Tell me, who is it about?
It's only fragments.
Nothing's clear.
You've been fighting the Harkonnens for decades. Yes.
My family's been fighting them for centuries.
Your blood comes from dukes and great houses.
Here we are equal
What we do, we do for the benefit of all.
I very much like to be equal to you.
Maybe I'll show you the way
deal with this prophet
Send assasins, Feyd-Rautha
He's psychotic.
I see possible futures all at once.
And in so many futures, our enemies.
Prevail, I do see a way.
There is a narrow way through.
My alliegance is to you
You believe me?
This is a form of power
that our world has not yet seen.
The ultimate power.
I want you to
know I will love you as long as I breathe.
You'll never lose me as long as you stay who you are
Consider what you're about to do
Paul Atreides. Silence!
This prophecy is how they enslave us
Chani!
You are not prepared for what is to come.
Welcome back everyone, It's Charlie
They dropped a brand new dune
Part 2 Trailer, so we'll break it all down.
There's a bunch of brand new footage
And the director,
Denis Villeneuve, has talked about doing the third movie,
which would be based on Dune Messiah,
which is just like the next book in the series.
So we'll explain what's going on with that
there's a couple more books they can actually adapt
in the movies before things really start to get weird.
And I don't know if they would continue as movies
or eventually just shifted to a long running TV series,
But if you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
They also bumped out the release date,
so now it's coming out at the beginning of March.
We had to wait quite as long.
if for the most part,
the directors also corroborated this, but
he feels like this movie in this kind of bears out in
the trailer is a much more action
heavy movie than the first movie
which is way more contemplative.
basically starting with a giant battle
that Paul sees in one of his dreams.
You see this giant explosion.
The other thing, too, is when they started
the trailer here in his dream and you see the explosion
is that you see what looks like a giant bubble of water
coming from the ground,
which is a foreshadowing for
what will eventually happen to Iraq as all the water
and their creatures that they've been storing
in those underground tanks, essentially basically
foreshadowing Iraq is eventually becoming
a very green paradise, no longer a desert,
which is also very deadly consequently to the worms
which are critical to the spice.
so even though normally you would be really happy
that Iraqis would turn into this green, lush paradise,
it presents a huge problem for the universe,
especially development,
because if you can't travel around the universe
using spice, it slows everything to a crawl.
it within the lure of dune.
There's really only like a few people
that can actually travel around the universe
without guild navigators and spies.
that he wakes up from the dream,
which Chani telling her about it.
Basically about one of the ways
that he's seen talking about the way
through this upcoming
conflict with the Empire in the harkonnen.
He talks about this later in the trailer
when he talks about seeing a path through all this.
That's the whole idea with his powers is the Kwisatz Haderach
The term literally translates
to a shortening of the way.
Part of the idea is that he can see
all potential futures, So if he can learn to fully use
his abilities, he can actually like literally
just see the potential timeline, like Dr.
Strange Avengers Infinity War style.
They could lead them through this
like the one in 4 Million Chance where they could
actually make it through this a little bit of that
successful path through this that they'll have to take.
Also comes from the princess played by Florence Pugh.
she becomes a much bigger character during this
like they teased her in all the previous trailers
but she's much more present on Iraq in in the story
in this trailer
when she tells Paul that it's been a while
since you had one of those dreams.
The idea is that a little bit of time has gone by.
He's been living with her
in this relationship for a while.
we get a really quick montage
as he's telling her about his dream.
Probably the most notable thing during this is them
holding the water of life, this blue fluid.
It's basically the bile of the young sandworms.
It does a number of things,
mostly fully awakening the powers inside of him.
But it's also taken by new Reverend Mothers
Awakening their powers as well to part of the idea
is that when his mother, lady
Jessica and Paul, join the Fremen,
she becomes their new reverend mother
and takes the waters of life herself.
There were some teasers for that during the first movie
where he sort of seeing the future
and seeing her with all those tattoos over her face
as the new Reverend Mother
You see him using a thumper
summoning one of the sandworms.
This is in training all the fremen in their atrocities,
fighting techniques
to give them an edge against the harkonnen troops
and the Emperor's sort of car troops.
Then we see the princess played by Florence Pugh.
this is actually a flash from the final battle
that they have against the emperor's throne ship.
it'll be really interesting
to see Denis Villeneuve's vision of all the emperors
stuff inside his new vision of the Dune movie.
a lot of his design language inside the first Dune
movie was based
a lot of the original concept art
for Frank Herbert's version of Dune.
Then he sees a vision of Austin.
Butler is fade in what looks like just a random scene.
Like he doesn't look like he's
wearing his military uniform.
there's another flash of what looks like
the final battle with the fremen charging
against the sort of car and the horsemen and troops
and the emperor's throne ship.
when he says nothing's clear touching the sand, he's
trying to find the potential path
that they could take
that will allow them to win this upcoming conflict.
then I think in this voiceover
he's still talking to Chinese, saying
that you fought the Haqqanis for decades,
My family's fought them for centuries.
That is true.
Like they've been fighting for hundreds
and hundreds of years, even longer than that,
I think I talked about this in previous videos,
but like in the history of doing
like the thousands of years of history in Dune,
The bitter entity between House Harkonnen and house
Atreides actually started during one of those
original major battles were I believe House Atreides
accused the Baron of house harkonnen
at the time of cowardice Then it became this big feud
between their two houses
that lasted for thousands of years, with each house
going after each other, killing a bunch of people
on both sides up to present day.
so, even though it seems that
there was a lot of backstabbing that happened
during the events of the first Dune movie,
stuff like that has been happening
between their houses for thousands of years.
but in this scene with the voiceover
they're actually cutting some footage of the fremen
attacking one of the harkonnen spies Harvester ships
one of the really notable things that they gave
Chani way more action scenes during this
than they have in previous versions of Dune
on screen when the first movie came out,
a lot of people were asking about that.
Like Chani wasn't really in that movie.
He really show up to like the very end
and he basically explained
that same thing, like, well, he's
not really a big part of the story
until like the next movie
where she becomes a very, very big part of things.
when she says your blood comes from Duke's.
Obviously, they show the burning picture of his father
Leto atrocities in his mother.
but there's a lot of symbolism here.
When they show his mother as the new reverend
mother of the Fremen that's a big thing all by itself.
Like her just becoming the new reverend mother
obviously huge deal but on top of that,
because of the whole bene gesserit plot
to bring about the Kwisatz Haderach
this whole breeding program that they have
his mother is also secretly the baron's daughter.
So he also has the blood of Baron Harkonnen
running in his veins they kind of alluded to this
during the events of the first movie, but Jessica's
mother is actually Reverend mother Mo Hiam.
they don't really get into it during this trailer.
But they do have that Dune TV series
that they're doing on HBO.
Like HBO is basically doing what they calling
Dune Prophecy, which is meant to be a prequel
to the events of the first movie, all about the bene
gesserit in their secret plan to bring about the Kwisatz Haderach
breeding program of theirs.
we get a quick flash of still gar in the frame
waiting for something.
this actually seems like a flash of what
the final battle is going to be between Paul in Fade.
One more time.
Tony references the way, quote unquote,
like the whole idea of the Kwisatz Haderach
means a shortening of the way
the couple big bite scenes from what looked like
the big final battle we get a little bit more VOICEOVER
from Emperor Corino, played by Christopher Walken,
talking to his daughter, the princess,
telling her to deal with Paul atrocities.
he basically tells her to send assassins after him
and she comes up with the idea to send Fayed
we get a little bit more scenes of him on Katie Prime
in what looked like the gladiator pits,
getting ready to fight someone Then he talks to Chani
about seeing all of these possible futures all at once.
It's all just part of his powers.
As the Kwisatz Haderach
seeing a way through this, essentially.
in a lot of it comes to a compromise between him
and the horror cannons in the ember
We get another quick flash of what looks like
the final battle in Gurney Halleck leading a bunch of
Fremen against a big revenge fight against Raban
Harkonnen for the events of the first movie
Good old fashioned Revenge
when he says he does see a potential way through this
they show a quick scene of them leading
a bunch of sandworms against the sidecar car troops.
there was a speedrun version of this
during the David Lynch version of the movie.
But they're sort of jam packed.
The events of the entire book into a single movie.
basically they cause all the sandworms
to attack the shield wall all at the same time.
this looks like it's still on JD Prime.
they haven't fully revealed
what all the ships look like in dunes.
I'm not sure which ship this is.
This actually trying to land on dune.
it might be the emperor's ship.
This is Paul going to meet his mother
with a bunch of other reverend mothers near her.
then we get Reverend Mother Maryam
talking to the princess about poetry.
This Kwisatz Haderach Powers trying to explain
why he's so dangerous.
all these scenes of them attacking the shield
wall look like they are from the final battle.
they're bunch more scenes of them
attacking the spaceships
this looks like more of the Hawkins
trying to attack the fremen inside their sieges,
this looks like it's actually from the final battle
because you have all the fremen here with Reverend
Mother Mohammed.
And boy, pretty much everybody else
crowded around this center here.
any basically successfully uses the voice against her,
just showing how powerful he's become,
where he barely was able to use the voice
against his mother during the beginning
of the first movie this just seems like it comes
before the final battle where he's getting ready
to lead all the fremen against them.
this scene with the giant sandstorm coming to the city
just seems like them leading the sandworms to the city
to break the shield wall.
a like I said, just very action heavy trailer
because the entire movie is just way more action heavy.
there's a bunch of stuff going on in this trailer,
like it's a long trailer to begin with,
but there's just so much plot packed into here,
so much lower.
So there's anything you spot in the trailer
that I didn't talk about during the video, just right
up below in the comments or any big questions
you have about what's going on,
I think depending on how Dune part two does,
they will greenlight part three
and that will basically be the events of Dune
Messiah in they'll probably just do it as one movie.
then they probably try to do Children of Dune
as the movie.
And then like I said, after that, once they get to God
Emperor do, that's when they might try to pivot
to a long running TV series depending on how long
this Dune prophecy HBO series, winds up running.
there's a bunch of big stuff coming up.
I've already done
videos on the other Dune part 2 trailer
so I'll post links for those in the description below.
Everyone click here for my new House of the Dragon
Season 2 trailer video with a whole bunch of footage
and click here for my brand new Deadpool
3 Wolverine video with a whole bunch of footage.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!